Oh
[Music]
all right welcome to GD 50 lecture seven
this week we'll be talking about one of
my favorite franchises of all time a
core part of my childhood Pokemon is
shown by the pokeball on the screen
there so back in 1997 I think it was the
first Pokemon game was released red and
blue I believe it was released a year
earlier in Japan where it was released
as red blue and green and the overall
goal of the game was fairly
straightforward you were a pokemon
trainer your goal was to go out into the
world and try and capture any number of
a hundred and fifty-one different types
of these creatures called Pokemon that
were you know based on a whole bunch of
different types of creatures that shown
in the screenshot here or there's a
weepinbell fighting a Geodude - Geodude
wasn't rock-type weepinbell was a grass
type you had different types of Pokemon
when they fought each other some types
were better than other types like this
sort of very large rock-paper-scissors
relationship and it was just a very
addicting formula you'd have a team of
these creatures that you had caught and
raised and battled and you'd fight other
trainers and the awesome part of this
was you could go and you could actually
fight your friends or trade Pokemon with
your friends that they had caught and
you would often share stories back and
forth about the different rare creatures
that you had encountered and all sorts
of things you'd have a customized party
that was sort of a part of you and so
this is pokemon red the series has
evolved over time this is a screenshot
of gold and silver which was released a
couple years afterwards for the Game Boy
Color again this was released for the
regular Gameboy
gold and silver introduced a bunch of
new features including breeding and a
day/night cycle and a lot of other
things that became part of the core
series here's a ruby and sapphire which
was for the Gameboy Advance and got a
significant graphical update but the
core formula stayed much the same here
is diamond and pearl which was for the
DS which was made use of two screens as
seen on the top and bottom there here's
black and white which was another step
forward in that it introduced
three-dimensional graphics for the
overworld so you could actually see sort
of 3d for the first time in the
franchise and then more recently we've
seen for the 3ds games like X&Y which is
shown here and
megha sapphire alfred ruby alpha
sapphire Omega Ruby and Moon and Sun and
so this is a great illustration of the
RPG genre video games role-playing game
even though it's sort of its own unique
take on the formula but it allows us to
we can sort of dissect this and take a
look at what makes an RPG and what makes
a pokemon game all together for a nice
cool demonstration so today we'll be
talking about a few new things we'll be
doing things a lot differently in this
lecture example relative to other
examples because we're transitioning
away from the state machine and talking
about a construct called the state stack
which is effectively a more advanced
version of the state machine whereas
before we had you know a state machine
that was in one state at a time whereby
we could be in the play state or the you
know the start state or whatnot we can
now actually have multiple states that
exist in parallel that are on a stack
data structure which you've seen in cs50
if you've taken where we can have for
example the field state the play state
at the very bottom which is always there
and then we can push States onto the
stack as we need to for example a
dialogue state so that we can actually
display some dialogue some text to the
screen without getting rid of the play
state that we had there before and
allows us to render multiple things at
the same time and then also return back
to prior States rather than completely
create new States every time we want to
make a transition I'll be talking about
turn-based systems so in RPGs like
Pokemon and others there are often
battle systems that are usually
turn-based in this particular genre
where you're fighting you have one team
or one character fighting against one
other team or one other character and
you take turns fighting each other and
you have an indefinite amount of time to
make your decision and then form some
sort of strategy as to how you want to
approach the problem we'll be taking a
look at a very primitive turn-based
system but a fully functional one today
another huge aspect of this genre is
graphical user interfaces or gooeys as
they're shortened things like panels and
scroll bars and text boxes and menus all
sorts of these things that allow us to
get a more visual
we'll sort of look at our data and allow
us to navigate a much more complex game
ecosystem more efficiently and to tie it
all together RPG mechanics at large
we'll be looking at things like leveling
up and experience and how to calculate
you know the damage that one party does
to the other party throughout the course
of a battle and so it'll be a fairly
complicated set of examples but fairly
illustrative of that of the genre as a
whole so I'd like to demonstrate sort of
the example that I put together if I
could get a volunteer from the audience
to come up and take a look taani to be
awesome thank you so much so this is my
simple but fully featured more-or-less
demonstration of pokemon so if you want
to hit Enter or return
so this is a so here we have a we can
see right off the bat we have a text box
and a play state like we did before so
this text box is actually a state that's
layered above the play state so you can
see you have some instructions about if
you want to press P you can heal your
Pokemon you can press ENTER to dismiss
so if you go ahead and press enter
you'll be able to actually move around
now and so something to note is before
input was actually halted while the
dialogue was on the top of the screen
for the play state you're actually not
allowed to access or update this bottom
state because the state stack is only
allowing input for the top state and so
I've limited the play state here just to
this box but if we walk in the tall
grass down here in Pokemon in order to
actually initiate an encounter with
another Pokemon or another wild Pokemon
you walk in the grass so here we've
walked in the grass there's a random
chance for this to happen
everyone intends there's a 1 in 10
chance basically so it's saying that a
wild bamboos 'no peared so a wild
creature appeared these level 5 where
level 5 should be a fairly even battle
so you can press enter and it will say
go your name of your Pokemon which is an
art art in this case and it's randomly
allocated at the moment so can press
enter one more time
now we can see on the bottom right we
have a menu so we can fight or we can
run so those two choices so we go ahead
and fight so if we fight whichever
Pokemon has the higher speed we'll go
first and do
we obviously do a lot more damage but he
goes fat he's a little bit faster so
he's gonna go first
so he fight one more time we should see
we should be able to knock him out so as
soon as we do we get a victory message
we get a victory song if he press ENTER
we'll actually get some experience for
defeating that enemy so we've got quite
a bit of experience at sixty-five XP and
that bottom bar we can see we have all
these GUI elements we've got a panel
here we have text boxes we have progress
bars all these pieces are you know
coming together to give us sort of this
turn-based system and so after this we
may level up just to demonstrate
leveling which is part of the RPG
mechanics side of this game so and press
it one more time Oh beat it perfectly so
they leveled up and so now we're level
six we can see that the six changed on
our above our progress bars so now we'll
be a little bit stronger every time and
the stats aren't shown here it's
actually part of the assignment is to
create a menu that will actually show
you how you leveled up what stats
actually increased but beneath the
underneath the hood behind the scenes
you actually are getting stat increases
and so here we can see that if we are HP
goes all the way down to zero we faint
and when we faint the screen instead of
going fading to white it will actually
fade to black to illustrate the
difference between the two transitions
and so that we can keep playing
indefinitely the game will restore your
Pokemon back to full health and so this
will go on forever this is effectively
what the simulator is it's just a simple
you know series of infinite battles
they're random Pokemon in the grass
there's a five total that you can fight
but all the core pieces of what make the
game are here so actually let's
illustrate running to if you wouldn't
mind just so we can see if there is a
difference so we can actually plea and
then the battle will get cut short there
don't get any XP we won't faint but we
still get taken back to the play state
so that's all for the Pokemon demo
thanks so much Tony for coming up to
demo
there's a lot of pieces involved here
but as we can see as we will see once we
have a lot of these sort of foundational
pieces implemented it's not too
difficult to start layering more and
more of these on to the game to make it
even more rich in fact the assignment is
to and we'll see this at the end I'll
recap this at the end but the
assignments goal is for you to implement
a menu similar to the menu that we saw
where fight and run were shown that
allow you to that will show you what
your current stat is for each of your
stats there's attack and defense speed
and your your HP it'll show you what
your stat is before levelling the amount
that it'll increase by and then the
final amount which is sort of similar to
how the actual Pokemon games work so you
can see rather than just seeing oh I
increase my level from 5 to 6 6 to 7 you
can see Oh my strength increased from 12
to 14 I'm a little bit stronger I'm
gonna do more damage on the next
playthrough so our goal here we're gonna
take a look at the field state the place
state and the battle state and there's a
common dichotomy in most of these sorts
of games be it Final Fantasy or Dragon
Quest or Pokemon where there is a field
where you are walking around you're in
you're a character interacting with a
game world with NPCs going through towns
and what-have-you and then a battle mode
sort of a battle state where you're
actually fighting against some sort of
enemy or a series of enemies a party or
a single creature and so we've
implemented simple versions of both of
these to illustrate and also the
transitions between them before we start
I want to make another sort of plug for
this how to make an RPG calm this book
actually learned a lot from this and
about using Lua in the context of game
development and I pitched this I think
in one of the earlier lectures but if
you want a deeper dive into a lot of
these constructs and to sort of get a
sense for how you might do something
like cutscenes or more complicated
battle layouts and a lot more like there
it goes into a lot of detail about a lot
of awesome things definitely check it
out it's not free but if you're
interested in this genre which I am it's
definitely worthwhile here's what the
sprite sheets look like that we'll be
using for this short demonstration the
Pokemon aside which are individual
textures here we're using a simple
sprite sheet which just has a bunch of
tiles most of which we did not use note
that the bush the tall grass is not on
any sort of background and we are layer
therefore we need to layer basically
have two separate tile maps as opposed
to one which we didn't do last time and
we're reusing the sprite sheet that we
used in the zelda lecture before we used
it for all the enemies the skeletons
ghosts and slimes etc but now we're
actually using it for the NPCs that it
contains specifically just the male NPC
here which is our main character the
foundational class that we're using in
this lecture that sort of everything
else revolves around and makes this work
is the state stack and so before what we
had was a state machine right we're in
one state at a time so you can almost
think of it like we have a box here and
it just has one socket and then we're
always looking at this one socket
whether that's the play state or the
battle state or a transition of some
kind and now we're transitioning into
the idea of instead of just one state
that we can only see at once we'll make
it a stack and so what we can do with
this is rather than just having one we
can therefore render multiple states at
a time right so let's say this is the
like the field right or the play state
and then maybe this is like a dialogue
or something right like like we saw
before in the in the field we had a text
box we can actually layer things on top
of each other and then maybe this is
like a fade out right or a fade in so we
start with the place state maybe and
we're walking around and we interact
with an npc rather than transition the
place state to a dialogue state which
would in our previous model completely
eliminate the play state because there's
only one state that could be active at a
time now we just render however many
states we have in our stack we just
render them sequentially based on the
order that they were popped in we render
this first we basically render from the
bottom-up render the play state then the
dialog then the face
and this will have the effect of doing a
whole bunch of different things which
we'll see in the distro but we only
really ever need to update one state at
a time right because if we're if we have
the play state active and the dialogue
state active and the fade in state
active in this order as a stack right we
were pushing the operation for pushing
for getting something on to the stack is
called a push and getting an office
called a pop if unfamiliar if we're
pushing all of these states on then
usually we only need to update whatever
is on top right if we're if there's no
fade in for example and we only have a
dialogue state active or a dialogue and
a play state in that order
top to bottom then we usually don't want
to you know update what's going on in
the play state we're only concerned with
the dialogue that's taking place we only
want that to take input and when we
press spacebar enter or whatever button
clears that dialogue state we pop it off
right and then we're back to the play
state then we're just updating the play
state and so being able to update just
what's on top while being able to render
everything that's on bottom and this is
doesn't hold true for all game formulas
you know there's certainly some games
where you can have a dialogue and a
place they both get updated and but
that's still using a state stack of
sorts you're just then updating things
in a top-down way but this allows us to
do all kinds of things like trend
transitions and preserving like for
example the fact that we have a play
state and we can pop a battle state on
top of that where we don't see the play
state underneath it we only see the
battle State and that's all updating but
as soon as we pop the battle state off
we're right back where we just were in
the play state it's preserved its State
for a lack of a better word from before
and this is something that this model
affords us comfortably and so that's
sort of the foundational class that's
implemented in this district aynd zuv
awesome things so let's go ahead and
take a look at what that looks like
I have States AK open here so state
stack has just a set of states here
and then whenever we want to insert a
state it's gonna be at the end of the
state stack so it's going to be whatever
the last so if if we're looking at it as
a series of states in a table it'll be
whatever the last index is in the table
that'll be our the top of our stack and
you can implement this either either way
in Reverse if you wanted to it's just
easier because you can just do a simple
table dot remove to get rid of the table
dot remove on that table to get rid of
the last state without having to shift
back everything so if we if we did it
starting at index one you'd have to
shift everything back and it also be a
little bit weird because you would start
at one and then things would go left but
basically in order to update whatever
our end state is we just do at number
self dot States which would be however
larger states a state stack is we just
call update on that state and then
process AI is here that we're not using
it but it would if you had AI would be
the same thing as basically an update
for artificial intelligence for your
state rather than rendering just one
state at a time we iterate through all
of our states here using AI pairs which
will iterate through them numerically
starting starting at one going to the
end so we call for I state and i pairs
of self dot States render it so that'll
render everything from back to front or
both bottom to top and allow us to get
this layered look where we have a play
state going on underneath for example
and then a dialog on top or we have a
babble state going at the very top and
maybe that battle state itself pushes a
dialogue state to this top of the stack
or a bunch of other states a transition
we know whatever you would like to clear
it we just reset the table to an empty
table to push a state we just do an
insert on that state and then we call
enter on that state as we did before
sort of similarly with state machine
when we change to state we would call
enter on it and exit but now we're just
calling enter when we push and then to
pop all we do is call exit on whatever
the last state is in our state stack
and then just call table dot removed on
self dot states and by default when you
call table dot remove on a table just a
table with no other arguments it'll pop
it'll remove whatever the last index is
of that table so it makes sense does
anybody have any questions as to how the
state stack works all right awesome so
let's take a look then at the start
state so this is the start state fairly
simple we just have a couple of text
labels and then we have just a randomly
assigned you know sprite going left to
right how do we think we're achieving
the movement yep time are not tween and
then we're just drawing any lips right
pretty simple and then when we press
ENTER note the transition those that
there's a trend there's a fade to white
and then a fade to transparent and so if
we recall from when we looked at match 3
how do we do this do we remember
exactly and the rectangle was stored
where
sorry to repeat for the camera we had a
rectangle that filled the entire screen
and we just tween the transparency for
it which is which is true the rectangle
there before though was stored in
whatever state was active at the time
which was like the start state or the I
think begin game state was the name the
actual state that wasn't necessarily
relevant at the transition but using a
state stack we can actually decouple
this idea we can take the concept of a
transition and because imagine if we
wanted to make a transition between
every single state that existed in our
game right if we wanted to transition
from the battles of the field or the
field to the you know to the battle or
whatever else we might want a like to
start to the field we would need a
rectangle in every single one of those
that has an opacity that we're keeping
track of and that's not necessarily
germane to the purpose of that state
right so because we now have a state
stack we can actually abstract out this
idea of a transition and turn it into
its own state we can have a transition
state and recall that since we're just
layering everything all these states and
we're rendering them sequentially having
a state that possesses its own
for example opacity rectangle we can
just layer that push that onto the stack
and render that and it'll give us the
illusion of you know having this
transition but we don't need to actually
have it be part of the state that we're
trying to transition out of and into
does that make sense so let's take a
look for example at the feo let's take a
look at the start state first just we
can see where that actually gets kicked
off so the start state we kick off some
music we have a sprite and a sprite X&Y
these are values that are relevant to
the sprite that's moving actually we
only have one sprite ever moving left to
right it just gets teleported to the
right edge of the screen as soon as it
gets taken to one edge so we only have
one sprite one X&Y and then every three
seconds as we see here we have a
callback function that will tween the
sprites X to negative 64
over 0.2 seconds there really quickly
and then on finish teleport it to the
right and then do the same exact thing
but teleport but tween it to the center
over 0.2 seconds and then as soon as we
press Enter or return
note this here we have a G state stack
not a G state machine anymore and we're
pushing it pushing onto it a fade-in
state which takes in an RGB a duration
and a callback function now the if we
look at main.lua this is relevant
because now we no longer have a state
machine right we previously had a global
state machine G state machine we would
give it a list of indexes and two
functions anonymous functions those
would return the instantiation of a
state and then when we call change the
state machine it will index into its
list of states and call that anonymous
function which would have the result of
changing the state to some state that
we've implemented as a class right now
we just create a state stack and we just
push a new start state onto the class
and so what this will do is effectively
the same thing only now we can layer
things on to the start state right or
play state or whatever we want to and
we're not going to ever get rid of it I
mean we can get rid of it but we don't
have to for the place data especially we
want that toe pretty much never get
popped off the stack because that's
going to preserve all of our information
we're gonna default back to that to
store all of our character information
our Pokemon information whatever else we
might want to add on to this you know
shell of a game in inventory etc a world
state at large we want to preserve that
and keep that consistent across all of
our battle states and so forth and the
battle states will just pull information
from that world from that play state and
construct a battle as needed does that
make sense ok so here we're effectively
the only real changes we've made to
Maine are no longer a state machine now
we have a state stack I'm gonna push a
start
that start state has some behavior just
like any other state that we've
implemented before and what I was about
to get into before was here on line 36
of the start state we are pushing
another state on to the stack so there's
already a start state and it's from
within the start state itself actually
we are going to take in we're going to
take that stack which is one level deep
and then we're gonna make it two of
those deep now so now we're gonna add a
fade in state and the fade in state as
we can see takes an RGB does anybody
have a guess as to what the RGB is
relevant for yeah
- whether you want to fit in black or
white yes any color we could make this
we could make it a fade to red if we
wanted to our fade to blue but we don't
have to create two separate classes for
a fade in white fade in black you know
fade out black fade out white we can
just give it a color and then I mean we
could even go in go a level further with
this and make it taking an opacity as
well so that we don't need a fade in
state or a fade out state we just need a
fade state right and the fade state will
determine based on whatever last opacity
parameter we give it the right way to
fade in and out but in this case the -
the difference between the fade in stain
the fade out state is one knows to go to
zero want us to go to 255 that's really
the only key difference and then this
one D duration right we need to tell it
how long to fade and then this last bit
here is a function we're giving it an
anonymous function this is a callback
function because the fade in state by
nature is an asynchronous state it does
this behavior over time so we need a way
we need to tell it okay when you
finished doing what you're doing call
this bit of code here so that we can we
can do something not immediately we can
just sort of defer its execution till
later and this is something that we'll
see common throughout this lecture
because we have this implemented also in
like dialogue for example because we
don't know when the user is going to
press spacebar on the dialogue state and
clear the window but what if we want
that window that clearing of that
dialogue to trigger some sort of event
right for example if they press enter
when they're in the battle we want it to
go to the next action we don't
necessarily know when that's gonna
happen so we'll just pass in an
anonymous function to that dialogue
state that will tell that will that the
class will call whenever the close
function is called on that dialogue
state says when closed execute this
anonymous function and then that
anonymous function can do whatever you
want to do take you it could pop another
several states onto the stack but this
is what allows us to change
asynchronous behavior that's the key
here
so this anonymous function so we'll take
a look now actually at the fade in
stages we can see what this looks like
so we see here fade in state right takes
in the color we saw before that'll be
the color we fade to the time the length
of time that'll take us to actually
perform the transition and what are we
using for the transition do we think
timer dot tween right so most everything
that we'll do actually throughout the
course of this the course of this
lecture that has a synchronous behavior
we can implement it with timer which is
nice it allows us to succinctly fairly
succinctly and declaratively tell you
know write out what exactly we want to
have happen over time in this case we're
going to tween over the course of time
the opacity of our self to 255 so the
fade in is going to fade into the full
color of whatever we've given it so it's
going to go from zero which is shown
here by default to 255 and then as soon
as we finish that tween that is when we
pop the fade in state we're going to pop
ourselves off the state effectively off
the stack effectively and then here
we're calling on fade complete and
that's where the anonymous function is
on fade complete is passed in here so by
putting that function into the finish
function of the tween operation where
we've allowed ourselves to defer that
function that we've written up in the
was in the start state we deferred the
execution of this function until after
that tween operation takes place does
that make sense okay awesome and that's
effectively what it is and that's a
common theme that we'll see if you're
looking through the distro you'll see a
lot of places the anonymous functions or
callback functions rather being passed
into things like the dialogues and the
fades and a few other places in the take
turn State for example there's a
function that takes in a callback
function as well and that's effectively
how you can chain asynchronous behavior
that executes over time rather than it
being blocking does anybody have any
questions so far as to how this works
it'll cool all right so when the fade is
done if we're in that we're still in a
start state here the fade is at this
point the fade is done we're executing
this anonymous function we're gonna pop
the the start state off of the stack in
this case and then we're going to push a
we're gonna do two pushes here one is to
push a place state which recall is where
we're the NPC walking or the character
walking around and another one is to
push a dialogue state and so what this
will have the effect of doing is rather
than us immediately going into the play
state and being able to walk around
we're actually put right into a world
where there's a message waiting for us
that we have to press ENTER on in order
to continue and when we press Enter
because we're pushing the play state
first and then the dialogue state the
dialogue state is at the top of the
stack right because things get pushed on
to like a bunch of like a stack of
plates you put a play state plate on the
bottom and then another plate on top and
that plate is the dialogue state in this
case and you can only interact with the
top we're only updating the top plate at
wants in this model we could obviously
make a more complicated state stack that
allows us to Matla have
several layers of states being updated
at once but for simplicity we only opted
to allow the top layer to be updated the
dialogue state is gonna be the active
state it's gonna be receiving input all
of them are gonna be rendered so we're
still gonna see we're gonna get we're
gonna render things from the bottom up
we're gonna render the play state then
we're gonna render the dialogue state
but the dialogue states going to be
active we're only gonna be able to press
anything on that state and then lastly
actually even beyond the dialogue state
we're pushing another state pressing a
fade out state in this case it's the
opposite of the fade in state it just
takes an RGB and we'll go from 255
opacity to zero opacity in that case and
so what that allows us to do for playing
right.we we're here in the start state
pressing enter that's our fade or fade
in state was there and then we pushed
the play state and the dialogue state
and the fade out state at once so it
looked at you would almost think that we
pushed the fade in and then the fade out
but we have to lay that foundation
before we put the fade out state on top
of the stack right because the top stat
the top layer gets updated so we have to
push the fade out state on top of all of
those that will get updated that'll fade
out and then we're back to the two
states that we push before we push the
fade out state does that make sense okay
anybody have any questions as to how
that sort of flow works cool all right
so that's the gist behind I mean that
that's essentially the the core of what
we're doing today is the state stack
pushing multiple states and then just
figuring out the right order that you
need to push them in to get the desired
appearance that you want right we push
the fade out state while we're in the
start state they're fade in state rather
that'll take us to white and then like
sort of almost like underneath the you
know behind the curtain we're putting a
we're popping everything and then we're
adding the play dialog and then another
fade out state and so you sort of have
to balance the
order that you put things in and/or
achieve the desired results it may not
necessarily be exactly as you
intuitively think until you think about
just how we're updating and rendering
things on the stack and so that's the
ultimate hurdle I think in really
getting comfortable with a distro but
once you've gotten that everything else
sort of falls into place that and the
sort of abundance of asynchronous
functions as we'll see pretty shortly
when we look at gooeys and how we've
implemented a lot of basic GUI
functionality a lot of that is very very
callback driven just because of the
nature of it being based on user input
right you don't know when the user is
going to do any input so defer whatever
happens with that GUI code with the
triggers involved when the user presses
spacebar enter and then call that
function that you've passed into that
GUI widget all right so we've taken a
look at the state stack of take a look
at the start state the fade in state
let's take a look now at the play state
so the play state a lot of this is
actually very similar to what we did
back with Zelda which was just a tub
which is a very similar type of game
top-down view the only difference really
with that was RPGs of this nature
Final Fantasy Pokemon Dragon Quest there
tile-based to the degree of even your
movement is tile based and so we've
striven to implement that with this
lecture so when we move our player our
character it doesn't have free motion
like we like we did with Zelda for
example so I'll demonstrate this so I'm
gonna go to the field state here the
play stay sorry and then when I move if
I press right he moves in that direction
at a perfect grid interval so if I move
up I'm taking my hand instantly away
he's gonna keep moving and he's gonna
stick hard set to this grid and that's
just a sort of trend that these games
have implemented it allows you to stay
perfectly aligned with the grid and
helps you I guess certain game I don't
think isn't this so strictly necessary
for probably most of the games that
should choose to implement this I think
it was a symptom of tile-based games
from the NES and Game Boy era being more
easier to design and implement because
they're very tile based systems but I
mean even as an aesthetic choice I
suppose it makes sense because
everything aligns very perfectly so
that's the the core difference really
with the field stay in this game so how
can we go about implementing a grid
aligned movement system like this with
our player relative to how we did it in
Zelda for example how do we think yeah
so we don't have X and Y's we just have
the tile positions closed it's it's more
I would say it's more focused on the
tile positions but you still do need an
X and a Y because you still need to draw
that sprite at that exact position right
yes Tony exactly
so rather than moving the sprite
discreetly no exact pixel positions per
update you tween the sprite when you
receive input to a specific location and
then we actually stop input at that
point as well there's no no use for us
having any input when we're not exactly
at a given tile so we disable input
while he's walking effectively and so
this is implemented if we're looking at
the distro in the entity class there is
a leave it's in here
maybe player hold on is it oh sorry no
it's MC walk state not the entity entity
is just a container for the information
that's relevant so here in the entity
walk state we have attemptmove and so
what a temp move does is essentially
looks to make sure that we're within the
bounds of the map right and then if we
are we every entity in this game now has
a map Y and X and irregular Y and X and
so the regular Y and X we still need in
order to draw our sprite at you know
specific location on the map
we still need to draw it going between
you know 240 something and 230 something
right but we need a map X and a map Y to
basically say okay the the sprite should
be at this position on the map and then
we'll just tween it between that
position x 16 and that's how the
position plus or minus X or Y times 16
which will give us the exact X&Y value
that we need to draw it onto the map and
since we're doing here so when we we're
gonna call a temp to move on inputs any
time we we do any input and this is done
in the player like Idol or player yeah
player I'll class player idle state we
change the animations through our
animation and then we get its current
map X&Y and then based on whatever
direction the player is looking or the
entity is looking we could use this for
an NPC class or the like we just modify
our 2x and 2y so 2x and 2y is gonna be
the value that we're tweening towards x
16 right and so if we're trying to go
outside the map boundaries just change
us back to idle so let us do that
otherwise set our map Y and map X to
that position immediately right because
that's just a minus or plus one
operation and then over the course of
0.5 seconds actually tween to that value
and we can see here we're tweening to
the tile size and actually to the tile
size minus self that entity height
divided by 2 do we know
why that is we do that because if we're
looking at the field and see here notice
that we're not perfectly lined up with
the grass right it's kind of like we're
halfway above it because it looks just a
little bit more natural this way this is
how most sort of games look and if
you're in a game like this and you're
like walking up against a wall for
example this will allow you to sort of
look as if you're up against the wall
rather than sort of being you know at
the edge of where the bottom of the wall
is and kind of looks unnatural hence why
we're we minus half our height right
there and then when we're finished we
actually test to see whether we're still
pressing a key and if we are then change
your state to walk again which will just
repeat this process depending on which
direction we're looking at and that's
effectively it and that that's what
allows us to get this grid-based
movement any questions as to how this
works cool
so another let's take a look and then at
the play stage let's go back to it so we
have a level the level contains our
entity and it can contain all of our
entities and whatever objects you want
it to contain in this case when we're in
the play state as well we're gonna check
to see if we press P because this we
recall where we can heal our pokemon
just a little game hack just to make
demoing it a little bit easier but if we
press P we play a heal sound we take R
and then we'll look at a little bit more
detail as to this all this in a little
bit but self stop sorry self that level
dot player dot party that Pokemon index
one dot current HP equals self that
level that player departed Pokemon at
one dot H P so the difference is current
HP is whatever you currently have you
could have taken damage HP is whatever
your max HP is and this is like in a
nutshell how you get like you know stat
changes in games and RPGs and health and
MP differences you got to keep track of
a Max and a current value for all of
those things
and then depending on whether you're
buffed or D buffed or whether you have
taken damage or not or used spells or
not you can have an accurate reflection
of where your character is and then
always return back to that state
whenever you need to the interesting
thing here the more slightly more
complicated thing is when we press P we
want to show a dialog that says and I'll
demonstrate this we want to show a
dialog just like this one that says the
best change your Pokemon has been healed
right now I can't move I'm pressing the
arrow keys
I can't move my character at all because
this dialogue state we're in a new state
where we've popped I pushed a new state
onto the state stack and that's the
dialogue state here which has taken a
value and because it's the top layer of
the stack it can't get updated or it's
it's being updated and we can't update
the play state right based on how we've
modeled our state's tax operation or how
it works and then as soon as I press
ENTER it gets popped off
we've just popped it off now the play
states at the top I can move again so
that's what's going on so the dialogue
state then is actually very similar in a
sense to the fade in and fade out state
in that notice that it takes an
anonymous function when does this
anonymous function get called do we know
at the end of what yeah well when the
player when the when the user closes the
dialogue box
correct so let's take a look at the
dialogue state then and we can see it's
actually pretty simple it's pretty
straight pretty pretty small we have a
text that it takes and a callback right
the text is used here we instantiate and
this will see in detail when we start
looking at gooeys and all the widgets
that i've implemented here this text box
gets put at a hard-coded position and it
receives this text and then we set
ourself call back to that callback
function if
we've closed the text box meaning we're
looking to see self-taught text box that
is closed which is a function of the
text box class if it's closed then
executes self callback and then pop this
dialogue state off of the stack right so
it's similar in a sense to the fade in
and fade out and that it takes an
anonymous function the only difference
is in how it gets executed with the fade
in state the anonymous function was
called at the end of the finish function
which is part of the tween object in
this case we're executing the callback
function explicitly when we've closed
the text box so we're waiting for user
input versus waiting for some
asynchronous operation to finish and
then of course we call textbox render
and then we'll see all of these methods
shortly as part of these widgets but at
a glance this is all that's really
happening with the dialogue State very
simple using the same pattern that we've
seen of deferring future behavior to
anonymous functions any questions as to
how this works or anything so far cool
all right let's take a look back at the
play state I believe we're getting close
to being finished with the play state
yes so everything that's basically what
the play state is in this game and then
a lot of what what's going on takes
place in level as well so in this case
and in a nutshell we have two maps two
layers right because we because the
grass in the tile sheet is its own sort
of alpha out object is this have got
transparency around it we keep a layer
of the base a layer of the grass
underneath and then a separate layer for
the tall grass and then we can just look
in to see when we're walking in the
player walk state when we've walked over
tall grass and then what do we need to
do to start a random encounter
yes yes how do we initiate it that what
are we looking for well we we do push a
battle State when as soon as we've
triggered one but how do we trigger one
what are we looking for so it's yeah we
do a random chance whenever the players
on grass and it's whenever they start
the walk and they're on grass in this
case but you could do it either way you
could do it when they're leaving the
graphs walking into the grass in this
case it's whenever you press the button
and they happen to be on grass it'll do
a random chance one in ten and if it's
true if it's equal to one
ten percent chance it'll trigger an
encounter so that's the gist behind
triggering a random encounter and a lot
of these games really some games with
differently they'll sometimes make it
more likely the more steps you've taken
they like sort of keep a counter to say
oh I've taken 100 steps it should be a
lot more likely now some games will just
be completely random one in ten one in
five depending on how the developers
decided to implement their game the
former is a bit more robust but for
simplicity we just chose math dot random
ten equals one so so yeah we create the
the tile Maps here pretty straight
forward and then the actual random
encountering takes place in the player
walk state so here we have check for
encounter and so what this does is
whenever we enter the walk state which
is we press the button to enter or to
walk this enter function gets called
because we do the transition to the
player walk state in the state machine
the all of the entities are still using
just a regular state machine not a state
stack wasn't necessary for this
demonstration though I'm sure there are
some use cases for using a state stack
for an entity in this case we're just
using a regular state machine so when we
change to the walk state we are calling
enter as we've seen and then we call
self check for encounter and so self
check for encounter will set a flag if
we have
not started an encounter basically and
will allow us to move and if we have
check for an encounter it will if we
have triggered an encounter it will push
in check for encounter it'll check it'll
actually push a battle state onto the
stack so check for encounter just
basically does what we said before if
the grass layer because we have two
layers right we have the base layer and
the grass layer so if the layer @yx
where we are Y X's are entities map X
and map Y if the ID of that is equal to
tall grass and we have just a global
constant table called tile IDs which has
all these IDs in math at random 10 is
equal to 1 okay change the entity state
to idle so don't let them keep walking
pause the field music rather than
stopping it so that way when we come
back to the field later and we press
play it'll be at a the exact point that
it wasn't before
trigger the battle music and then we've
seen this already fade in state push to
the stack right so over one second we're
going to fade to white so there's lot
the effect of the music starting but
what we're fading to white right away
which is very sort of similar to how
most RPGs do it and then we have our
callback function which will execute as
soon as the fade in States done right in
this case push a battle state battle
state takes an entity and the entity has
all of our Pokemon information that's
where we passing that into the battle
State so the bowel state can say oh
what's my Pokemon do you have ok I'll
create a I'll be able to look at your
party and say ok your first Pokemon is
this send him out to battle it's that
right right and then lastly push a fade
out state right because now we've got
the battle state on top of the play
state but we want to fade into it right
so we're going to fade we're gonna put a
the battle state first and then because
we're using a stack we're going to put
the fade out state on top of that and
then fade out to that pop that off the
stack and then we have our battle state
that we just pushed right and then self
down counter found gets it he
and that's that's creating an encounter
checking you know randomly pushing the
right things onto the stack battle state
fade state fade in/fade out and then
you're set to go so that's that's
effectively what the would be it's known
in RPGs as the field versus the battle
the you know battle or encounter state
we've even though we're calling it play
state here we've left the field we've
gone into the battle at this point and
so now we've seen basically everything
that the field has to offer us and we've
covered everything that's relevant there
so we're gonna take a break now for five
to ten minutes and then when we get back
to back from the break we'll talk about
GUI elements panels text boxes and then
we'll dive into the sort of mechanics of
the battle State all right welcome back
to lecture seven Pokemon so before the
break we talked about the play state we
talked about the state stack more
importantly than we talked about how a
anonymous functions are sort of the
backbone to how we get a lot of this
asynchronous and deferred behavior for
our game which is very common in RPGs
and I mean a lot of genres a lot of
complicated genres of this sort another
big key part of games like this are the
graphical user interfaces or gooeys as
they're shortened to things like panels
on the screen things like labels text
labels that move around things like a
lists you know check bar sorry
text boxes scroll bars you can get a lot
crazier with it in this particular
lecture we'll be talking mostly about
things while we're talking mostly about
panels labels text boxes and scroll bars
progress bars rather not scroll bars mmm
but the sort of the first I think corner
or the first sort of like Keystone GUI
widget that we should take into
consideration is the panel so a panel is
clear that we this clear
hey Sophie look at this in a game just
pretend this is a panel I guess so this
is a what effectively all a panel is
right it's just a server rectangle it
allows us to if you're looking at most
user interfaces
you know like text boxes on your screen
or if you're on Facebook and you're
looking at you know almost anything like
your little message window a lot of
those things at the very core the very
bottom the foundational parts to panel
so any guesses to how in love 2d we can
make a simple panel two rectangles at
different colors that's exactly what we
end up doing so that's effectively how
we can make a panel there is another way
of making a panel which we won't do in
this lecture but it's called we uses a
construct called a nine patch so a nine
patch is imagine taking this little
image here and it's of some arbitrary
size but it's very small and this is
very similar to how a lot of games
implemented their panels or their
graphical user interfaces back you know
in the 80s and 90s I mean a lot of games
till this day but back when hardware was
found a fundamentally tile-based you
could take a image like this split it up
into nine pieces nine patch is where the
terminology comes from and sort of
somewhere to how we actually construct a
Bozell the dungeon recall where you have
corner pieces and then a top bottom
right and left side you just layer this
you one of each of these first off right
of the corner pieces and then however
many you need of these on the sides to
sort of create this rectangle right so
imagine we've created you know these are
all
if you can visualize these as being a
bunch of tiles right
so just imagine that we've taken these
corner pieces these are the corner
pieces we've taken one of each of those
and then we take these side pieces and
we just like draw a bunch of them like
that and then we take this centerpiece
and then we can either layer it or tile
it a bunch of times or just stretch it
and stretching it has a bunch of nice
bonuses associated with it depending on
how you've set your filter mode love
graphics set default filter if you set
it to bilinear versus nearest you can
actually get a nice gradient and if you
set it to nearest you get a nice
pixelated look but you'll see this often
and unity has a nice support for this
take an image that has maybe more
complicated than you could get with just
two rectangles right something that
actually has a design and maybe a
gradient color and actually a layer and
actually I mean you know create a
arbitrarily sized text box to fit your
needs and you know if these aren't even
increments of whatever your tile size is
on your nine patch you could just scale
the top bottom left and right sides as
well just like you would scale the
centerpiece so does that make sense so
this is comic won't we won't be using
that in our lecture but it's a very very
common piece to a lot of graphical user
interface design and a lot of games
you'll see it a lot if you get more into
game development so it's definitely
worth talking about another piece that
we'll be talking about today is the text
box so I mean what's a guess as to what
the text box how we can implement a text
box now we will have a go to text box
so what foundational piece can we start
with
we already have yeah you just put use
the love fruit to the screen over so use
the love print to the screen over on
those boxes exactly yep so maintain a
list of text items write text and then
just draw them you know inside a panel
and there's a text box you've taken two
ideas and sort of mix them together a
selection is kind of the same thing it's
a the only difference being that with a
selection so a selection is another
thing if we think about for example a
menu where we have fight and like run
and it may be in a more fleshed out game
we have like an item thing right so
that's a that's a menu effectively it is
a very similar to what we get with a
text box but it's got a set of
ingredients here fight item Run which
aren't you know they aren't set to rap
they're not one like contiguous set of
text it's just it's a bunch of items and
then a nice thing about a selection is
that you know you can have a cursor on
your selection right and then what do we
need to associate with like for example
if we want this to actually do something
and if we think about what we've been
doing so far how do we go about
implementing functionality with a
selection like this like what what needs
to get associated with each of those
entries in our selection
callback function right just as we've
done with everything else if you have a
fight item here you know each of these
if we think of the selection as being
just this part of what we're looking at
right because this this background part
is just a panel we don't care about that
we care about the selection at the
moment the selection is the items and
the arrow right and as we'll see in the
assignment your goal will actually be to
take selection and get rid of the arrow
functionality because for the assignment
you don't need or want to have a
selection active a cursor active you
just want a list of things but based on
what the cursor is pointing at and where
we we know when we press enter or
whatnot
we should index into the selection and
then execute a callback that's
associated with each of these items and
that's how we can get behavior out of
the selection rather than it just being
a list of things that we render to the
screen if we have fight and when you
click enter a callback is set to maybe
push a state onto the stack that will
trigger an interaction between the two
entities on the screen right the first
one will attack the second one the
second one will talk the first one and
that's sort of its own asynchronous set
of states that do its own thing but it's
kicked off via an anonymous function
that take that we've associated with
each of these things right an item
pushes another state which is like an
item menu state where then you open up a
brand new set of menus that you can look
through all your items and each of those
items has a callback associated with it
right your potion has a callback
associated with it that says when I
click on this either by default just
restore the HP of my active pokemon or
let me choose whoo to restore so you
know
therefore push another state which is
like a select Pokemon screen with its
own set of callbacks associated with
each of those it's just in order to get
all of this sort of complicated you know
behavior that you need to it's really
ultimately just pushing states and
adding callback functions to all these
different options that you can select
and then run pot you know push a fade
state and then pop this state and then
push a fade-out state and that's really
all we're doing and so this look at all
of these GUI widgets here is just sort
of a
conceptual look but we'll take a look at
very shortly at some actual
implementation the last one that I want
to look at is the progress bar so a
progress bar for example the HP that
we've seen you know on the in actual
battle where you know when we take
damage it goes from right to left any
guesses as to how we've implemented a
progress bar yes honey
two rectangles yes exactly one and then
the nice thing about rectangles in love
2d is you can set the edges on them to
be rounded or not by an optional
parameter so without anything more
complicated than a rectangle we can just
create these sort of almost ellipsoid
progress bars very simple progress bars
ones the red right the red that's the
background and then one's the outline
the black and that's one is set to fill
with the first parameter once it's
aligned with the first parameter now how
do we go about animating whether or not
you know how do we animate the the
decreasing amount of health when we take
damage yes between the width exactly and
what are we tweening it by how are we
tweening it how we calculate how much we
need between it if your width is set to
equal your health remaining then your
health is maybe 10 and you want your
health bar to be like a hundred pixels
long how is that gonna work though you
could multiply it but if you know the
width that you want your progress bar to
be you can just multiply the width by
their ratio of the max value of your HP
or sorry the ratio of your current HP
over your max HP right so if you're
missing if you have 50 HP and you're
missing 5 HP your ratio is 45 over 50
and if you multiply that by your width
you get the exact amount of width that
you need really you know regardless of
how wide you want the bar to be if you
wanted to be a thousand pixels you want
to be 50 pixels as long as you multiply
current health over
max health times the width you'll get
that ratio no matter what so make sense
cool so that's that's a look at all the
GUI widgets that we're looking at how
they sort of relate to what we're doing
we'll take a look at their
implementation here so I'm going to go
ahead and open up the panel and I'm
going to move a little bit quickly so we
can get into the sort of the meat of the
battle here the panel is as we've said
before just two rectangles right it
takes in an X Y width and height and
then we just draw two rectangles one is
larger than the other the bottom
rectangle is slightly larger than the
top rectangle so the first rectangle
gets drawn and it's white ish and then
oh I'm sorry sorry about that we have X
Y width and a height and then we're
drawing two rectangles to the screen we
have the background rectangle which is
drawn first which is going to be the
full X Y width and height of the panel
and then we're gonna draw that at a
white color and then draw in this in the
context of this game we're drawing
everything at the same color but we can
change the color if we wanted to
parameterize that we could do that we
could set you know we could have a color
option here in the constructor we're not
doing that we're just drawing everything
the same color but that's how you'd get
like customized menus some RPGs let you
do that
you could and then what we're doing here
is we're just within a small slightly
smaller boundary so just two pixels
smaller on the X and the y where you're
gonna draw the second rectangle which is
a kind of dark shade of grey and that's
that is a panel that is all a panel is
and then we could just have a function
called toggle which sets it's a visible
or not visible and if it's visible you
know get rid of it or if it's visible
sorry draw it otherwise don't draw
anything when it gets rendered so that's
a panel in a nutshell any questions cool
so the next thing that we should look at
is the text box so a text box so this
text box is a little bit more
complicated than a panel a text box in a
nutshell needs to take in some arbitrary
body of text and needs to chop it up
based on how Y do text box is and if it
served
passes the height of your text box right
ideally you should page your text so
that you can press spacebar enter and go
through pages of text until you've
gotten until you've exhausted all of
your text and you press enter one last
time and you get rid of that text box
and so we have a panel here which is you
know we have an X Y width and a height
in our constructor for the text box and
we have our text as well and then we
have a font if we want to explicitly
decide what font we want to use in this
case or at large we're going to say that
we instantiate a panel at X Y width and
height nothing too fancy and then the
fancy ish part assembly more complicated
part is here on line 20 where we say
underscore self dot text chunks and gets
self dot font get wrap self dot text
self dot width minus 12 so anybody know
what this function does or want to take
a guess
yes exactly it's the page it's the
paging of the text
it's the chunking of the text rather or
not not the paging of the text so much
it is the chunking of the text which we
will use to page the text so we take
some you know arbitrarily large body of
text can be as large as we want it to be
and given this is actually a function of
the love 2d font object so this is given
to us from love 2d get wrap will return
two values the second of which is all of
the P all of the pieces of text that are
that the main big body is divided into
based on the width so this self dot
width of minus 12
that's how wide it's going to divide our
text into chunks of up to it could be
slightly smaller than because it divides
it based on the word but no piece of
text will ever exceed self dot width
minus 12 width and this will allow us to
then render several several lines of
text within our text box and they will
never exceed the boundary right and so
the paging functionality is actually in
next chunks so we call self next here at
the end of our knit function and then
self next basically checks to see okay
are we at the end of the text if we are
then we're not going to display any text
and we're gonna close the window we're
gonna close the panel but if we are not
at the end of the text like we still got
text left we want to do is new table and
then we're going to up to three
iterations we keep it we keep track of
where we are in our chunks right we get
self text chunks equal to all of those
chunks right and that could be an
arbitrary number it could be it could be
only one chunk there could be like 30
chunks right we need a counter to keep
track of where we are in terms of like
you know based on what page were on
right and what however many lines we've
rendered to the screen thus far so
starting at I and I gets chunk counter
and chunk counter will get incremented
by three every time we call next chunks
which is every page we could just we
could have easily just called this next
page as well it's gonna insert into that
chunks table that we just created
self love text chunks that
and once we've reached the number of
chunks total that we returned from get
wrap or in ass flag end of text as being
true and then we're gonna return it and
so what this will do is eventually we're
going to be equal to the number of
chunks that we got from font and get
wrap right and once we are that will
signal with next that it's time to close
the text box because the end of text
will have been set to true at the end of
that last chunking process and then we
can see here when we update text box and
that's whenever it's on the top of the
stack remember we're looking for a space
or an enter press and then we just call
self next and that will have the effect
of eventually closing our text box and
then is closed recall we looked at that
earlier we took to see it or is the text
box closed and that's just a flag that
we set here and then for rendering
purposes we render the panel first and
then for each of our displaying chunks
so we only have up to three displaying
chunks at one time which gets set by the
next chunks function we just print that
to the screen using I as a multiplier on
our Y and so that will mold that will
render up to our three lines I I plus 1
I plus 2 any questions as to how the
text box works it's a little more work
than the panel for sure but it's fairly
straightforward you know we're just
keeping a list of a bunch of text things
and then we're just chunking them based
on how wide the text box is the
dimensions thereof and then let's take
one look at this selection so a
selection is a basically a list of text
items with a cursor right and as I said
before when we were looking at the
screen over there each of those text
items has a text value and a callback
function and the callback function is
what allows us to assign behavior to
this selection object beyond just
displaying things right because when you
have a menu when you have a selection
and you select something you want
behavior to happen
right so each of these items in deft
items will expect to have a callback
function and then here when we update
the selection what we're doing is we're
updating whatever our current selection
is which is just a number between 1 and
the number of items in that selection
making sure that we if we're at 1 and we
go minus 1 that we go back to the bottom
and if we're at the bottom when we press
and we go up 1 we go back to the top and
we play sounds you know cutesy things
like that and then for each bit in for a
selection here for from 1 to number of
items we calculate how much padding that
we need and we draw the cursor at our
current selection and then we draw each
item based on I and whatever our gap
width is of our panel which we assign it
to so we divide our panel up and then
basically just keep track of where our
current Y is and draw the actual
selection and the cursor if that's the
current selection to the screen any
questions as to how a selection sort of
works and notice here the if we press
return if our selection is being updated
self
items at self dot current selection dot
on select so it's it's it's expected
that that item will have an on select
function which is that callback function
ok and lastly we'll take a look at the
menu and then we'll finally take a look
at the battle which is where sort of
everything kind of comes together with
all of this and that'll be it and then
we'll talk about the assignment so the
menu is a panel in a selection together
that's there's the gist behind what a
menu is in this game a menu you can
define a menu to be a lot of things and
you can get a lot more complicated with
a menu but in this example and this
implementation we're just saying a menu
is a selection and a panel put together
as one item and we've seen it in the
game if I go ahead and run it
that's just a text box gonna look for a
battle okay so here's a battle that's
just an empty panel at the bottom
regular panel but now it's a text box we
push the text box onto the stack push
another text box onto the stack and so
this is a menu right here notice that
there is a cursor and a and there's a
selection embedded within a panel and
each of those items the fight and the
run those have a callback associated
with them fight the call back the
purpose of the fight callback is to
trigger a new state where the tooth
Pokemon asynchronously attack each other
and / and chain behavior one after the
other and then run pushes a dialogue
then pushes a fade state then pops both
of them and then take pushes a fade out
state and puts us back to the play state
so that's effectively what's going on
and that's an example of what the menu
look like and so a menu just a selection
with a panel put together when we draw
the menu we draw the panel and then the
selection and then when we update the
menu we only update the selection
because that's all we care about
that's basically it and so the menu
itself will get a def that def should
have items that items will get passed to
the selection that's pretty much that's
it for the progress bars as well well
look at progress bars when we get to to
the actual battle State so now let's
take a look at a few of the classes and
data structures that are pertinent to
the Pokemon themselves so if you look at
party as our first class very simple
class literally just this so if the
Pokemon is def top Pokemon it is just a
container at this point you could take
this I mean even in I think a fully
fleshed game you wouldn't really need
much more than just this but if you need
to expand upon this idea at all and you
know preserve metadata that exists for
the party this would be a perfect way to
do it the actual Pokemon class itself is
not a whole lot more than effectively a
bunch of stats and that's a lot of what
an RPG is
this genre is it's mostly just numbers
you're just comparing numbers against
numbers and then adding a roll of the
dice and that's effectively that's
that's what Dungeons & Dragons a lot of
it is and that's yes say it one more
time
wouldn't it make more sense instead of
storing your HP and everything for each
level to store your initial stats each
area and how much he would go up the
level would it make more sense to store
in the amount that you go up per level
for your Pokemon yes that is what we're
doing well so we have a base so here's
here's how the split works for the stats
in this case right we have base HP based
attack base defense and base speed a
level 1 Pokemon has a level 0 Pokemon
has these stats of this of this species
right every bamboo nor whatever pokemon
that we choose will have whatever we've
allocated it to be its base HP based
attack based defense based speed and
then the thing about Pokemon and I mean
a lot of RPGs will turn do this thing
but we need some way of leveling up the
Pokemon in a non necessarily
non-deterministic way like two piggies
that level up may not have the same
stats right one might have slightly
higher attack than the other one might
have slightly higher defense than the
other we do this using what's called an
IV and that's what Pokemon itself does
it's short for individual value and this
is sort of like the DNA of your Pokemon
right so this HP IV is separate from
your base attack base speed based etc
and this basically it gets compared
against a dice roll every time you level
up three times so if you have in a dis
dice roll is and this is this is how
I've programmed it it's not necessarily
how Pokemon itself does it but you will
roll a dice a die six times or three
times one through six like a normal die
and you'll look to see if that roll is
greater than your IV right
or it'll check to see whether your IV is
less than or equal to that dice roll and
if it is or sorry if it's greater than
or equal to that dice roll and if it is
it will increment that stat by one for
those three dice rolls so you can get up
to three more or you can increase the
step up to three times per level but you
can only have an IV up to five so you're
rolling against a six and you will
occasionally not roll a six it's it
checks to see whether or not the IV is
greater than or equal to the dice roll
and if it's not greater than or equal to
the dice roll and they in the event that
it is a six or if the IV is a up to a 4
for example which means a five or a six
will go against it then it will not get
a stat increase and this is a sort of
simple way of implementing this DNA
based system it's randomized but it's
weighted right if you have a higher IV
you have a higher likelihood of being
greater than or equal to the dice roll
and so that's how we implement stat
increases and then we need a way of
keeping track of what our stats are like
our actual stats so our actual HP our
actual attack or actual defense an
actual speed that's been calculated
level by level we need a way to keep
track of that we need a level we need
our current XP and then we need our the
amount of XP to gain a level which will
get higher and higher per level as you
can see here because it takes in the
self dot level times self dot level and
then it multiplies that by five times
zero point seven five and then your
current HP so we can't so we're not
we're really not storing our value level
by level we're storing we need the base
because we need to know what our base
was I mean we could we could effectively
globally reference these variables but
it's minor it's minor efficiency gains
at that point but we need the IVs and we
need the I mean we need a reference to
the IVs we need a reference to the base
HP and we need a reference to we need to
keep track of whatever our actual stats
are
and then our current HP always because
our HP you can differ from our actual HP
and in the actual game you could have
your attack defense and speed also very
match by match because you have moves
that lower your speed lower your attack
lower your defense etcetera in this case
we haven't implemented that so we don't
have a current attack current defense
but in a more complete implementation
you would have that sort of thing that's
sort of answer your question is that in
the right pane okay
and so here's yeah here's the level up
code so like I said at three dice rolls
one two three
if six is less than or equal to our IV
so it could be a six in which case it
will be greater than what our IV max IV
could possibly be IVs range from one to
five but if it's less than or equal to
that IV then we're gonna consider that a
stat increase it's a weighted a weighted
odd in term to determine whether or not
we get a stat boost and does this for
every stat and then it returns all of
the increases and this is relevant this
line 95 for a return HP increased return
to tech increase defense increase this
will be relevant for assignment seven
because your goal is to take these
increases and actually display them to
this user in the battle state when he
gets a victory or he or she gets a
victory and has gained a level you need
to see will display a menu with a
selection that has all of these things
and you'll need this value so it returns
this value these values here and you'll
you can call you'll be calling this
function anyway from your battle state
stats level up or we will be calling
level up rather which returns self stats
level up and that's all a Pokemon is and
we use this data it's effectively mostly
a data structure and we use this in our
battles to you know throw dice
effectively back and forth and have a
victor and a loser and then gain XP gain
XP and gain levels that way so any
questions as to how a the Pokemon object
class works
we'll take a quick look at that what the
actual definitions look like which you
can probably take a guess it very simple
just key names and then we have the
actual name we have the sprite names we
have the HP attack/defense
all the things that get put into the
actual object they need a reference to
in the definitions and so Pokemon
ultimately are just this they're just
data right which is what we talked about
in a prior lecture data-driven design
the more you can take all of your
Pokemon and make them into or anything
Pokemon or any object and turn it into
it easy to write data structure like
this the easier it is for you to add
more we could easily add you know it
wouldn't take too long to create a
hundred and fifty of these I mean there
wouldn't be all that interesting because
we don't have moves implemented yet but
in an ideal world we'd find a way to
also model moves as data and therefore
you can just link moves to your data
structure to your Pokemon object like
this yes Donny do you have question oh
like Crusader Kings oh yeah they'd the
paradox could comment was paradox games
are very good about data-driven design
I'm assuming you've dug through their
files and also this just if you play the
games for a while and just it's
everywhere like the source code oh yeah
yeah no I mean it's it's just good game
design ultimately if you want to and
they're their games are large they have
a lot of content if you want to have a
lot of content in your game you need to
find a way to take the burden off the
programmer and put it on to the designer
or at least make it easier for the
programmer because making source code
and debugging source code all day long
especially very complicated things is
not easy and it's not ultimately not a
desire thing to do right it's a lot
easier for me to whip up a new creature
in ten lines of code here and feel good
about it then you know hard-coding a lot
of these sort of things right so
shifting as much of it to data as you
possibly can is should be your end goal
so that's what Pokemon deaths look like
before we get into the actual battle
we'll want to take a look at what a
battle sprite is so a battle sprite
is what the what was rendering on to the
screen right so we take a look here
that's not a battle sprite but almost a
battle sprite that was just a texture so
if we get into a battle slowly but
surely
all right so these are battle sprites
and they don't look much different than
a regular spray and they're not that
much different than a regular sprite but
they have some functionality that's
important mainly that functionality
where one was flashing and then one was
being opaque right so in order to do
both of those things we need to store
some sort of data within our sprite
right yes yes exactly
what we used in zelda for the
invulnerability flashing it you know for
the enemy or for the richard say for
whoever's getting attacked yes they are
getting an opacity flag stored in they
have enough lat opacity flag stored in
their object that's we can't win right
we can't win on and off over the course
of time as what we did with the entity
in Zelda when it took damage and we said
it's invulnerable and wall was
invulnerable with flashing on and off
but we can't necessarily do that with
the sprite that's blinking white because
there's not really in it like white flag
right we can't like we can't make
something completely white with just a
flag that's something that we actually
need to use a shader for and so a shader
and we're not going to get into too much
detail about this shaders are pretty
complex a little arcane at first but
what they are is effectively a little
program that runs on your graphics card
and that looks at when you're drawing
something it looks at every pixel
depending on what kind of shader you're
doing but for the sake of this
demonstration we'll look at every pixel
that you're drawing to the screen and
perform some sort of function on that
pixel and produce a new value right and
this is how you get a lot of really
crazy awesome things to happen but it's
it can be pretty insane shader toy I
think is the website that has
a ton of really cool I'm not gonna pull
it up now just said I don't remember the
name I believe it's shader toy there's a
website where people post all the
shaders that they've written and you can
see a lot of really crazy stuff things
that you would never imagine we're
possible with just you know code like
this effectively looking at positions of
pixels and positions on the screen and
whatnot but effectively what this does
this is a white shader the goal of this
shader is to just turn a sprite
completely white that's all the goal of
this shader is so it gets a float called
white factor which you say here and then
white factor effectively is just going
to be summed onto whatever
the RGB is of that pixel whatever pixel
that were drawing when the shader is
active what that has the effect of doing
is white factor if it's equal to one
here's the thing about shaders and a lot
of this stuff a lot of the like the data
structure within shaders are based on
floats that are from 0 to 1 so if we
assign the RGB of something to a Veck 3
that's 1 which is 1 1 1 that's going to
be 255 255 255 therefore that pixels RGB
is white pure white right and so what
we're doing here is on our battle sprite
self dot blinking and 1 or 0 remember
that's the Lua ternary operation so
we're saying if self dot blinking is
true one else zero so send our shader
white factor at whatever value self dot
blinking it like based on whatever value
self dot blinking is and so that'll have
the effect of the shader getting a 1 or
a zero and adding a 1 or a zero to the
RGB of that sprite and if blinking is
set to true the sprite is going to
basically be drawn every pixel at 255
255 255 otherwise it will get drawn with
whatever that images pixel value is at
that position that makes sense ok
the syntax is a little bit weird but
that's what's happening here in this
shader and there's a link here where I
found the shader but it's a very simple
very simple shader probably like one of
the simplest shaders you could write
but it's a great example of what you can
do with a shader and pretty simply and
it's nice because you can take like
texture coordinates and do math based on
that or pixel coordinates and do math
based on that you can pass in like a
sine function for example in your file
and have that sine function perform work
on like an art or G or B value of your
sprite and do all kinds of cool stuff
it's really neat like the possibilities
are limitless with shaders but that's
how we get it to blink because you can't
do that outside of this I mean there's
probably some weird way you could get it
to work as well but this is how we get a
this is probably the simplest way we can
get our sprites blinking white and so
self dot blinking just gets timer dot
every you know 0.02 or 0.1 or whatever
we'll actually see that in the attack
state but that'll flicker that'll flick
the self dot blinking between true and
false
it'll negate itself over and over again
all right so that's the battle sprite
last thing we'll look at is another
extremely simple class opponent all the
opponent is is up it has a party that's
it but in a fully fleshed game your
opponent might have a black trainer
sprite a message that it says like a
full party of Pokemon a gold value
that'll give you when he defeated all
kinds of things but it's here just as a
simple illustration yeah
laughs the room or something like that
Oh method yeah we could have a method we
can associate a method with an opponent
called on defeat or whatnot that will
like do arbitrary things collapse the
room or otherwise yes absolutely
or even push a new state like did like
teleport us to a new like location in
the world map maybe we like cleared the
Elite Four and we want to get teleported
to like the end credits exactly
limitless possibility so let's go ahead
and take a look now while we have just
like 20 more minutes or so left we'll
take a look at the battle state because
the battle State and the states they're
in are probably the more complicated
side of how this works so a battle State
we have a player we have a bottom panel
the bottom panel for when we start the
state just for that part but otherwise
we're always pushing things onto it
whether we've started the battle or not
because when we're fading in sorry yeah
because when we initialize this state
we're also popping a we also pop a sorry
push a fade-out state onto it but we
don't want to trigger the tween of the
Pokemon sliding from left to right until
after that state gets popped so we have
a flag here which we'll get set to true
on the very first update iteration and
then when that gets set to true well
actually tween the Pokemon going left to
right and begin kickoff all the other
sort of asynchronous processes that
exist thereafter but let's look look at
the battle one more time just to see
what's going on
so I'm gonna walk until I get into a
battle okay we got a battle so notice
here the Faden happens as soon as the
like the slide it happens as soon as the
fade starts right as soon as the fade
finishes I should say we get a message
popped under the screen right it says a
wild X appears right that's the enemy
Pokemon we hit enter turn it down a
little bit we hit enter and then we pop
another push another state on to the
stack another battle message which is
very similar to a dialogue state says go
our Pokemon and then we push a menu onto
the screen right we've got a menu that
says fight or run a selection oh it's a
menu which has a selection and then now
this is this is the top of the stack
right so it's the only thing getting
input nothing else everything else is
rendering beneath it but nothing is
getting input so we have the option to
either fight or run let's say we fight
we fight we've got a new state now we're
in an attack state several things just
happen so what happens when as soon as
we kick off the attack state yep so we
go first thing we have happen is a text
box that says X attacked Y where it
could be either the it can be either us
or the opponent because it's based on
whoever has the higher speed and then
what happens next well it does so so
let's so look at it right now and tell
me what what exactly happens as soon as
the text box pops up so what were the
what were the what were the pieces that
happen there okay so the attacker
flashes white right which is the shader
that we looked at that's the shader
blinking on and off there's some timer
that says every 0.1 seconds blink on or
off and then what happens
and that board so well damage is dealt
yes but what happens visually as soon as
the white blinks the other one blinks
what's the other one blinking so it's
opacity right so remember we're doing
the exact same thing we just did with
the white with the blinking but we're
tweening
every 0.1 seconds the opacity of the
defending Pokemon and then we take
damage then what happens when we take
damage well what what gets animated when
the thing takes damage we've animated
the blinky we've animated the opacity
the health bar drops right so we've
chained we're chaining several things
together we're changing first we're
doing the every point one seconds four
six times blink white then blink
the other thing opacity right and we're
playing sound effects at the same time -
we're doing a sound effect for the text
sound effect for the hit and then once
that's finished between the health bar
right so we've modified the health of
the defending Pokemon and then what
happens after the first one after that
process is finished
exactly repeat the exact same thing but
for the other side and then what about
what are we doing in between each of
those where do we have to do something
checking if somebody dies exactly and if
somebody dies let's say we die what
happens
well we yeah we go back to the place
date we fade out to black and then we go
back to the place date what happens if
we knock out the enemy exactly and what
happens on this screen so what's the
first that happens well so recall what
happened when when the pokemon died what
happened exactly so that's a tween
probably right on this Y value then what
happens exactly we've pushed a battle
message state onto the screen and then
what happens when we press enter what
just happened right there
yes correct exactly so we push a
dialogue to the screen that says you've
earned X experience points the XP bar
tweens right we've gone up to whatever
our ratio of current XP to next level XP
is we animate our text bar that way our
progress bar that way then we push a
fade outs to fade in state right to
white and then we have to pop everything
off the stack and then push another a
push a fade in or fade out state to the
top of the stack and then we're back to
the play state but if we do level up we
need to play the right music play the
right sound and then part of the
assignment will be actually in that
exact function you're going to need to
add some behavior that will do what
yes and what are we gonna need to do
what will we need to to do in order to
yes so once we've taken once we've
leveled up and we're in that victory
state of the of the battle state right
we need to push a new state a new menu
state which has all of those stats and
the amount that they've increased and
then when we press ENTER presumably we
should pop that off and then pop
everything else back to the play state
and then do the fade in as normal and
that's that is the battle State in a
nutshell a lot of pieces that sort of
are waiting on each other and input and
stuff like that but fairly easy to
understand just because a lot of it is
very simple things that are just chained
together over and over again to produce
this sort of interesting behavior so
here we have sprites recall the sprites
are what we're going to need to animate
those we have health bars which are
progress bars which are just two
rectangles that are ones a line a black
line and ones a fill the fills beneath
the line so that it can show we can see
we get a sense of how much it's how much
is missing right we get the width the
height a color we can give our progress
bar any color we want to which is how we
get the difference between say a health
bar and an XP bar we just make one red
and one blue and we draw them in
different spots right but they're both
equally progress bars and then we get
they get a value their value is whatever
sort of determines how much of the
rectangle is scaled and the max is how
much that should be divided by in order
to produce a ratio for the total with a
scaler for the total width which will
allow us to get the sense of an amount
missing and then a player circlex
opponent circle x for the ellipses just
the graphical details they actual
Pokemon so that we can see to get their
stats so that we can actually do dice
rolls or not really not really dice
rolls in this case but so that we can
add or subtract HP based on attack and
defense
and so here was the update so trigger
slide in
so what trigger slide in does is a
one-second tween which you talked about
right the pokemons going left to right
or left to right right to left they're
x-values just kind of tweening in over
one second as soon as that's finished
we're going to trigger starting dialogue
so the starting dialogue is push a
battle message state onto the stack the
battle message state is just like a
dialogue state and that it gets a string
here so I wild something appears it gets
a callback function for once we press
ENTER on that and the callback function
is itself another push of a battle
message state that says go and then our
pokemon so notice that we're referencing
the self that opponent dot party of the
pokemon there and self dot player dot
party dot pokemon there to get the
actual name and then once we've popped
that off then we push a battle menu
state here right let's take a look at
the battle menu state so this is
interesting because this is where we
actually define the behavior for how our
menu works right recall we need
something to tell us what happens when
we press fight and what happens when we
click run so when we click fight notice
here items write self that battle menu
gets menu and menu expects items this
items key this table gets fed right back
to the gets fed right into the selection
right and the selection will it expects
remember a text because I asked to know
what to render at that index and then an
on select function and then on select
function is the callback that gets
executed when you press ENTER at that
particular location in the menu in this
case fight what that does is it pops
this battle menu state or no we no
longer need the menu so pop it and then
push a new take turn state and then take
turn state in this game is the pokemon
fighting each other that's what it take
turn state is and it could have been
called fight state for example but take
turn state is a little more versatile if
we wanted to maybe make maybe one
pokemon wants to run the enemy wants to
run and we want to fight right but they
but you can't always run so they should
try to run
and then we can still fight them or they
can use an item or we can use an item
right there's a lot of different things
you can do or we want to throw a
Pokeball at them and if we if we fail
then they should fight us right take
turn is just a a general purpose state
that we could repurpose for whatever use
we want to with any interaction between
us and the opponent whether it's
fighting running away using items
catching them any of these combinations
of things but in this case for the sake
of this example for simplicity we've
only implemented fighting the we and the
opponent fight each other during this
state which is one attacks the other and
then we check for deaths in between both
of those and then go to victory or
fainting depending on which which which
of those holds true if either running is
slightly different so if we run
we've I've programmed it to be a hundred
percent it'll 100 percent of the time
work in Pokemon you actually have a
chance to run based on how based on what
the Delta is between you and your enemy
so if they're stronger than you you
actually aren't guaranteed to run away
so what we do here in my implementation
is we just pop the battle menu so it's
gone and then we push you fled
successfully to the screen this battle
message but there's a difference here
versus the other battle messages that
we've shown I mean it's not really
different but it's something to keep in
mind so I'm gonna get into a battle and
so first of all what that message that
you just saw the screen I had to
actually press Enter right I discarded
it explicitly by pressing enter and that
holds true also for these messages it
won't do anything until I press ENTER so
I press ENTER and then I press ENTER and
then does its thing but notice the
difference between when I put when I hit
run I'm gonna hit run I fled and it does
it on its own it's not waiting for input
right so how II implemented that
yeah
automatically do the same way you would
afterwards that instead of waiting for
your enemy you just wait for the timer
to act exactly so we use a timer and
then when the timer is finished we pop
the battle message just like we would
have popped it by pressing enter and it
this false flag is what allows us to do
that we press false and false is can we
input or not and we can't so actually if
we didn't do any timer thing after this
and we just did that false flag the
battle message would be the forever and
we could never get rid of it ever it
would get stuck forever so we got to be
responsible and say okay we're gonna put
a timer we're gonna call timer dot after
0.5 seconds immediately after that we're
gonna push a fade in state and then
we're gonna do these two pop operations
here as soon as that fade in happens
this first pop will pop the message
right this message here that we didn't
pop through input so this is actually
garbage collecting in a sense for us
it's discarding the message that we
didn't that we couldn't discard
automatically and then we're gonna pop
the battle State right so running will
push the battle message trigger a timer
tween for our timer after five seconds
sorry push a fade in state and then
after the fade in States done then pop
both of those states the message and the
battle state take us back to the play
state that's where we'll be as soon as
it's all done and that's really what the
that's that's all that's in the battle
menu state any questions as to how the
battle menu works um the difference
between fight and run and serve how
those operate okay so let's take a look
then at the take turn state which is the
last piece and the largest piece I would
say this is the most relevant to the
assignment so we maintain a reference to
which Pokemon is first or second to go
which sprite is first row second to go
and which progress bar is first or
second to go up here and we do that like
I said based on speed so
whichever Pokemon is faster and we could
have also made this a little bit shorter
just by keeping the sprites and the
progress bars as members of the Pokemon
object or the class but since they're
kind of separated like we don't
necessarily want a Pokemon to have a
reference to its progress bar at all
times or I mean me you could there's
nothing preventing you from doing that
it would all only serve the purpose of
shortening this code here but we need to
keep a reference to this so that we can
call attack here which is this large bit
of code twice without needing to
duplicate all of that code twice that
make sense so tonydd you have a question
sorry say it again I just kind of feel
like I guess you could take the code
it's just to see what you could do is
you could if you passed it into a helper
function which you would just instead of
passing it first pokemon player pokemon
or instead of passing it opponent
pokemon and player Pokemon you would
pass it player Pokemon
well you also have to take into
consideration so the comment was the you
could pass in the player Pokemon and the
opponent Pokemon into a function and
that would and then refers them in that
function I'm assuming have referenced
them and reverse them but the the
sprites are decoupled from the Pokemon
and the the progress bars are also
decoupled from the Pokemon so we we
could shorten this by making these four
things here member very are fields of
the Pokemon objects but they're not
strictly pertinent to the operation of
the Pokemon object and it sort of kind
of makes the Pokemon objects a little -
a little - not basically abstract or
lightweight enough and it only serves
the purpose at this point I'm just
shortening this bit of code there's
probably a more elegant way to do it but
it's hard to say if this code were to
get larger maybe but the gist of this is
basically to have a pointer to whatever
Pokemon progress bars and sprites should
operate first in the attack versus what
should operate second and then the two
will trade blows in order based on who's
first and who's second so when we enter
the take turn state we're going to
trigger that attack here this function
attack which will take in first second
first second first second for the
Pokemon sprite and progress bars and
then anonymous function which it's
executed as soon as the attack is
finished right pop the so this is a code
that will pop a message that gets pushed
in attack and then well this is where we
actually check deaths right and that'll
determine whether we go to victory or
faint screen or not if not and we return
if so if not we're gonna do another
attack but see everything is reversed
now now it's second first second first
excuse me second first so we have the
same function self attack which just
takes in the attacker and it's
effectively attacker defender attacker
defender attacker defender for the
Pokemon sprites and progress bars
and so the attack function here first
pushes a well okay what does the attack
let's let's go over it one more time
what do we think the attack function
does in order what were the sweetie we
covered them just a moment ago but what
was the order that happens when
something attacks another thing yeah
attacker blinks white if the defender
toggles its opacity health bar shrinks
exactly and then we and then that's
that's basically it for attack right
blink play a sound blink play a sound
shrink the bar and also we're doing
damage in that in that function as well
we actually have to change the stats of
the Pokemon so we do that in so we this
is effectively where it starts right
we've had a place a battle message state
on to the stack that says the attacker
named attacks the defender name notice
that notice that it gets false just like
the run message did because we're not
accepting input here but it's up to us
in the timer it's up it was actually it
gets done up here on line 42 of the
interstate but we're going to after 0.5
seconds play the attack animation so
powerup sound every 0.1 second we're
going to member the blinking flag on the
sprite we're gonna toggle it by setting
it not to itself so if something is not
itself if it's a truth eval you becomes
false Eve as false it becomes truth II
so basically toggling it between true
and false limit of 6 right because
remember every will do something every
amount of time indefinitely unless you
pass in a limit of some value in this
case limit of 6 so we're saying only
execute this code six times only blink
six times right only toggle toggle six
times blink three times right because
that's to go on and off and then as soon
as those six iterations are completed we
call the finish function on that timer
object which takes an honest function
soon as that happens we do the opacity
bit right we've blinked that we've
blinked the attacker so now I got to
blink the defender so we hit we play the
hit sound we do the exact same thing
that we just did for the blinking only
now every point one second we are
setting its opacity to either 64 or 255
depending on what the value of its
opacity is right so we're toggling
between 64 and 255 limit of 6 take a
function calculate damage which we've
just very simply done it attack -
defense right up to 1 though so if the
defense is actually higher than the
attack which is still do at least one
damage and then over 0.5 seconds we take
the defenders bar and between the value
equal to their current HP - damage right
and then that will set in that bar in
the progress bar it'll set its value and
even though the progress bar is behind
state-wise right it's on the bottom of
the stack because it's on the battle
State and we're in currently to take
turn state but because we're still
manipulating the values of that state
and we're rendering every state we're
actually still manipulating that state
regardless of the fact that it's not on
the top of the stack so that allows us
to shrink that pokemons progress bar
regardless of it being on the top of the
stack or not the ones that's finished
once the tween is finished actually set
the current HP to that amount because
we're only tweening the progress bars
value which is independent from the
pokemons value and then that's the end
of the attack the attack is completely
finished at that point so any questions
as to how the attack works just a chain
of tweens basically so we do an attack
then check deaths is the next function
and we're almost finished I'm going to
kind of go quickly here it's at 7:30
check deaths is the player pokemon
korean HP less than equal to 0 or is the
opponent pokemon korean HP less than
equal to 0 if the former is true we need
to faint and if the latter is true we
need to go to victory so faint is
effectively a battle state right
which says you fainted and then what
remember what happens when you faint it
leaves do you remember do you remember
what it how it leaves as it differs from
like running away from example well
beyond that aesthetically do you
remember what how it's different it does
it fades to black instead so that's how
we can differentiate you know when we're
fainting versus we're running away and
so that's what we're doing here notice
that the fade in state RGB is zero all
of those so it's going to fade in to 0 0
0 255 as opposed to 255 255 255 255 so
it's gonna be a black theta and versus a
white fade in and then once we've this
is just sort of a thing that I implement
it so that we can keep playing
indefinitely but once that's finished
restore the player Pokemon to full
health resume all the field music stuff
and then once we've pushed a fade out
state zero zero zero and then we've gone
back to the field let's push
notice that here it takes a function
right after the fade out states done
once the fade is finished so this is
right as soon as we're back to the play
state push a dialogue state that says
your Pokemon has been fully restored try
again which will take which will take
the context and will allow you to press
enter to get past it that's fainting
victory is a little bit more robust so
victory is do you remember what what
happens when we get a victory
well it has to check bubbling up as well
it says you've defeated your opponent
then your XP power increases then if you
so tells you defeat your opponent XP bar
increases checks for a level up and then
leaves after displaying the level up
message or not it leaves it put it pops
everything back to the play state
exactly so remember the very first thing
that happens though the opponent sprite
gets tweened over the course of 0.2
seconds it's y-value to virtual height
which means all the way the bottom of
screen right the typical defeated your
opponent from Pokemon sort of animation
once that's finished play victory music
push a battle message state this is
victory right once that's popped off the
stack calculate the XP which is I just
chose arbitrarily some all the IV's of
that pokemon times its level and that's
the XP you got push a state that says
you earned x XP right it's false so that
means it doesn't take input so that
means it's up to us in order to pop that
off the stack so after 1.5 seconds we
play a sound and then we tween that XP
bar going up right so that's what's
going on here self dot battle state dot
player XP bar
we're tweening the value of either way
of the map dot min of the XP + XP or XP
to level because if we don't it could go
past the edge of the of the XP bar
because we could go over our XP to level
right because we could gain let's see we
have 10 XP to again a level we could
gain 20 XP would be 10 XP overboard so
we don't want to tween our XP bar pass
the edge of the XP bar it would be a
graphical glitch so a math dot min our
XP + XP and our XP to level which will
take the lesser of the two values once
that's done it's tweened we're gonna pop
the message off and then we're going to
actually add the XP level up so this is
where we level up if the XP is greater
than XP to level play a sound set the XP
to the
at current XP - r2 level XP which will
mean that we'll have some carryover
right and then actually called a level
up function now here is where oh and
also after that congratulations you've
leveled up fade out white which is just
a white fade out here I used it twice so
I made a function for it just pushes a
fade in state play the stop the victory
music play the field music pop push a
fade out state so either way when we've
gotten a victory we're gonna push a fade
out fade out white or we're gonna call
fade out white correct so push the
battle message state and then as soon as
we press enter because we've leveled up
fade out to white and if we didn't level
up but we still got a victory we still
need to fade out white and so this is
where your assignment is assignment 7
assignment 7 is notice that we have self
dot player Pokemon level up the key
thing that we're going to need to do
here is add a menu that shows us how we
leveled up and if you recall player
Pokemon level up returns all the stats
that you've increased this level so you
can show a menu that just says your HP
Plus that amount right you're gonna get
all four values it's gonna explode all
four of those values and then you're
going to create a new Battlement or not
a new battle menu but a new menu of
whatever you want but probably on the
right side of some vertical height for
items the only difference here the only
key thing that you're going to take into
consideration is and I'll go back to the
slides because we're actually done at
this point going over the code but
there's selection items you won't be
able to actually select anything it's
just gonna be purely visual so you're
gonna need to edit selection to not have
a to have the option to not have a
cursor and this is detailed in the spec
which was actually released before
lecture today so you can take a look at
that but you'll need to make a change to
selection but all the pieces are there
it should be a fairly easy assignment as
long as you understand how the states
work how the menu works and how to get
the how to create a menu based on those
values and how to actually get the
values from level up so some
features that we didn't talk about which
we didn't implement are for example the
detailed level of screen which is your
assignment monster catching right we
only had a party of one Pokemon
throughout this whole entire thing but
then one of the arguably main appeals of
the game is to be able to catch more so
this is that'd be something to add to
prioritize probably adding to the game a
field menu so you can actually look at
all the Pokemon you've caught that would
be nice so you can actually see how much
HP they have in item inventory because
the game the regular games have items
you can use potions you can find gold
nuggets these sell for a ton of money
different abilities currently we only
have basically one fight operation which
is like a tackle and the game itself the
regular game is like over a hundred
different moves that have elemental
attributes and do different things and
cause status effects buff you or your
opponent so adding those is appealing
and maybe being able to represent them
as data is nice to trainers that you can
encounter in the game that have their
own preset or randomized Pokemon for you
to fight monster evolution because
that's like one of the funnest things is
taking a really weak Pokemon and like
raising it to become really strong and
evolving it at a certain level towns
routes other levels beyond just our you
know basic square area monster breeding
which is introduced in the second series
so that you can take two Pokemon and
have a chance to get an egg with a
really good stats or a really rare
Pokemon from it and then like a
day/night cycle maybe we're a different
Pokemon come out at different times of
the day so you are incentivized to play
at different times of the day for for
that purpose but that was it for Pokemon
next week will actually be diving into
unity so we're actually done with love
2d which is a lot of fun but now we'll
be going into how to make 3d games so
this is a screenshot from the game we'll
be making next week which is a 3d sort
of side-scrolling flappy bird esque
helicopter game based on a famous web
game called helicopter game and it was
sort of one of the early ancestors to
flappy bird on the Wikipedia page it
actually says that too I remember
playing it was back in like 2007 or
six or something like that but your goal
in this game this is a modified version
of that your goal is your everything's
3d but it's a side-scrolling perspective
so it's called this is called 2.5 D for
that reason you're controlling a
helicopter you're the purple helicopter
and your goal is to in an infinitely
scrolling world
so we'll revisit infinite scrolling but
in 3d avoid skyscrapers so you can see
there is a green skyscraper crudely
modelled collect coins so you can see
there's a coin there it's a 3d coin it's
always be spinning your coins are up at
the top right you'll see a background
that's infinitely scrolling and then
you'll have jets that will randomly fly
above you to sort of give you another
sort of layer or dimension of obstacles
to watch out for and this will teach us
a lot of the basics of how unity works
so we can start getting into more even
more interesting things like a
first-person like sort of core
exploration game and then lastly when we
end the semester with portal we'll look
at a couple of fancy things there but
that was it for Pokemon thanks for
coming and I'll see you guys next time